it has been a pleasure to watch these
recent barack obama rallies for joe
biden
socially distanced drive-in rallies in
various parts of the country
and part of the entertainment is that
trump gets so triggered by it
on one hand it's good to have a reminder
of what it's like to have a president
who speaks
incomplete sentences can articulate an
idea with a beginning middle and an end
but trump's triggering has been
delightful
here's barack obama in miami saying we
can't just
say it's okay for a president to lie
constantly
we can't just say oh it's fine if if a
president lies 50 times a day
no barack obama going on to say even
florida man the ubiquitous florida man
wouldn't do this stuff
why are we accepting it from the
president of the united states
florida man wouldn't even do this stuff
why are we accepting it from the
president of the united states
barack obama just laughing off the wacky
claim from trump that he's been
been the best president for black folks
since abe lincoln
and you know he he loves talking about
black unemployment
says he's the best president for black
folks since abe lincoln
what and then this one i just love
referring to the 60 minutes interview
uh with leslie stahl barack obama
acute accurately uh points out the acute
problem with a president not even being
able to sit
through a tough interview and let me say
i've run for president miami so
i just want you to know it's it's a good
idea to have an answer to this question
it's a good idea if you're running for
reelection to say
here's what i want to accomplish what
did trump say
he got mad and walked out of the
interview
he thought the questions were too tough
too tough miami listen if he can't
answer
a tough question like what would you
like to do in your second term
then it's our job to make sure he
doesn't get a second term
and that's why over the next 10 days
we got to work hard to elect joe biden
and kamala
harris the next president and vice
president of the united states
just very well done there by barack
obama uh one more clip for you
and i understand the president's coming
to florida today
you think he's hard at work coming up
with a plan to get us out of this mess
well i don't know because i know he's
had a tough week
everybody has been very unfair
to donald trump this week so again trump
hugely triggered by this tweeting out of
control
starting to tweet as barack obama was
doing these events for joe biden
nobody's showing up for obama's
hate-laced speeches
47 people no energy but still better
than joe
retweeting nonsense about joe biden and
barack obama killing the coal
industry as if that's a bad thing
it's not true but as if it's a bad thing
and if elected he will come after oil
and gas
which we hope he absolutely will and
then also tweeting just
wild quote just signed an order to
support the workers of delphi
corporation
and make sure we protect the pensions of
all american workers
obama biden failed american workers
and failed the workers of delphi i
always put american
workers first trump is so jealous of
barack obama it's so clear and for
good reason barack obama is able to
coherently express
political ideas he's able to connect
with people in a human way
you don't have to like his drone policy
you don't have to like his position on
uh warrantless surveillance or whatever
else
but trump has much reason to be jealous
of barack obama and
i love as a strategy bringing barack
obama heavily
for these last two to three weeks you're
not seeing george w bush out there for
uh donald trump
and in fact from what we've heard it's
quite plausible that george w bush is
not even voting for donald trump
barack obama will be a big presence over
the next eight days i think it's great
we'll be covering some of the events
live on youtube
twitch and facebook and i am sure that
the triggering will continue for the
next eight days
real quick i want to tell you about our
sponsor magic spoon
who have done something awesome they've
taken all of our favorite sugary
childhood cereals that we know we
shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult
there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
they taste great they're crunchy they're
sweet like you would expect this type of
cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free
gluten-free grain-free soy-free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
a
p-a-k-m-a-n